my name is kamal bob
i am the global lead for diversity
strategy and research
here at google the discussion today is
about race
and education and the future of a modern
technopolis
in order to get into that uh
conversation it's important to
understand the moment that we're
currently in
obviously the nation here in the united
states and in the world is in
flux particularly united states it's
relevant to reflect a little bit on how
we got to the moment that we're
in we are in a moment of
the conflation of a coveted pandemic and
a social uprising
inspired by the killing of george floyd
but in order to get into race and
education
we do have to pan back just a bit and
think about the ideological
transition that the country is in
however you might feel about those
things the reality is that we've gone
through national trauma
in the beginning uh at the shift of
these two ideologies
there was if you recall the women's
march
it was the largest demonstration in
american history
and it was revealing a certain kind of
angst about the
ideology that we're currently under that
was followed almost immediately by
an immigration debacle that led to
uprisings
in airports all across the country and
the ban from muslim
from immigrants coming from certain
muslim countries
we were followed that with the
government
shutdown which was again the longest in
the
history of the country and then there
was the impeachment
and all the while there was the angst uh
dealing with racial discord and animus
the
charlottesville demonstration led to
a time where people who are my age i was
born four years after martin luther king
was assassinated
people were my age having to contend
with words like the ku klux klan
and nazi affiliated organizations for
people again
in my generation those things are
artifacts of history but we had to
contend with them in real time
and then ultimately here we are in this
kobit 19 global pandemic
and all of the trauma that that's put
the country under and in the midst of
that
we had to confront the killing of george
floyd which has
sent us all into what i would call an
american spring
so discussing race and education and
ultimately what a modern technopolis is
it would be uh incomplete for us to try
to do that without understanding
at least contemplating the effects of
the moment that we're in
so relative to uh those two things
race and education the pre-existing
conditions idea is obviously part of the
lexicon now because we're talking about
a global pandemic
and the disproportionate impacts that it
has with people who have pre-existing
conditions the same is true in education
and one of the principal pre-existing
conditions that we're dealing with in
at least the united states education is
segregation
racial segregation specifically and
again here too
we have to be mindful of the fact that
we're not talking about racial
segregation
in 1954 previously we're talking about
it today
here in 2020 if you recall 1954 was
brown versus board of education
where we decided as a country that
legalized racial
segregation in schools in america was
illegal
separate is in fact an inherently
unequal
but here we are today i'll use
atlanta where i live as an example to
demonstrate the degree of racial
segregation that we currently operate
under
and this is by no means special to
atlanta atlanta happens to be
one of the top two most segregated
cities in the united states
and this graph crudely what it shows is
that
in the colors that are dark and gray and
black that's the predominantly black
section of the city
and those that are white are the
predominantly white sections of the sea
and that segregation is nearly absolute
and it correlates
with everything with the quality of
education with the quality of public
service
and in this current moment of social
upheaval it correlates with the kind
and quality of interaction with the
police whether you get garbage picked up
it certainly correlates with the voting
patterns that we see here
in the city but to make it even more
clear
relative to education i think it's
important for us to consider
how this actually plays out and
certainly for those of us who live in
the united states and have children
you know what this is like in the
schools and communities in which you
live
these the names here are immaterial but
these are basically the 11
traditional public high schools in
atlanta and all i want to illustrate
here
is that in essentially eight of those
schools
there are virtually no white students at
all and all of the students in the
entire atlanta public school system
essentially attend three schools so it
would be
in fact true if we put a sign here that
said
these eight schools are for blacks only
and harkening back to a previous time
those kinds of things are egregious to
our
sensibilities here in the middle of the
21st century
but this is the reality and even in the
schools
where white students attend those
schools within them
are also segregated such that the white
students have
better access to the advanced placement
courses to the honors courses to the
international baccalaureate
courses and in this instance i've been
to all of these schools personally so
these are not
uh it's not secondhand information i
know
in fact in part because of my role at
georgia tech i understand
how this works so this is
the the street level reality of the
relationship
between race and education we're
essentially still living in two
totally bifurcated systems with two
different sets of expectations
about what education means about what
education is offered
to one group of students versus the
other and clearly
that limits their ability to participate
when they move into the post-secondary
world to demonstrate that even further
at the georgia tech college of computing
i'm using georgia tech as an example
because i'm on the faculty there as well
i i'm the senior director of the
constellation center for equity in
computing
so i'm speaking on behalf here of
information that i
know well ultimately what we've seen
over the last
decade and some is that the
the fraction of black and latinx
students who have been admitted into the
college of computing
has only increased incrementally but for
asian and white students as you can see
here there's been a significant
increase principally for asian students
as you can see that
increase is dramatic but what that is an
indication
of is the basic infrastructure that is
segregated which is the pre-existing
condition that limits students
opportunity to be able to play in this
higher
level and that indicates of course and
brings us to the idea of what a modern
technopolis
is and in my construction of this
term when cities like atlanta like
chicago
like uh the bay area oakland new york
raleigh durham and the research triangle
park
they have built economic development
strategies that are
premised on the idea that tech companies
will show up in their country
in their regions and drive the economy
forward
and that is a reasonable expectation
particularly given
the disproportionate positive impacts to
economies that tech companies have
but what does that do it requires a
certain skill set
so when companies not unlike google are
planning for where these
locations should be they do an
assessment of the workforce and the
workforce's capabilities in those
places and in the current uh kind of
we're sneaking up on the end of the
first quarter of the 21st
uh century and this is this is news and
uh language that we all know uh what are
21st century skills what is the promise
of a modern technologist the promise is
that we will have people who have
computational skills who have technical
skills who have the wherewithal
to be able to participate in this modern
economy in some way
and that's a range from people who are
software engineers and advanced
computationalists
those who can use basic analytical and
numerical skills
to participate in whatever industry
whether it be art
cultural generation service industries
gig economies
etc so we have to agree that there is
some
certain level of numeracy and analytical
skills and technical skills
that make people able to participate in
what i call
a modern technology so the challenge
here of course
is that if we're thinking about what
citizenship
means in that space and here i don't
mean
citizenship in the litigious sense of
who
is legally able to qualify to be a
citizen
but rather citizenship in the sense of
mutual responsibility and the abate and
the ability to be viable
to be meaningful to be present and to
have
a means of contributing in this modern
technopolis in this modern economy
in order to do that you have to have the
aforementioned
skills but because the segregation
is so virulent and what it does is it
constrains the opportunity of certain
sections of these cities to be able to
participate
in the case of atlanta what i was
alluding to to make this case
ultimately is that we already know
that black students in the public school
system in atlanta
for example are segregated in ways that
lock them out of their ability to
participate
to get the access to higher ed
institutions like georgia tech
like stanford like carnegie mellon like
the competitive and selective
institutions and those of course are not
the only higher ed institutions
but when companies are planning where
they ought to go
particularly tech companies they use
those institutions
as proxy for the availability of a
modern workforce
so if we already know a priori that the
system that we have
completely and totally and structurally
locks out certain sections of the
population
and at the same time we build an
economic development strategy
that's premised on the fact that we know
that those students
can't compete we're building a future
we're building an idea of citizenship in
a modern technopolis without them
so that means the mass migration out of
technopolis's
technopoly if you like without
the black population the latinx
population the poor population rural
communities
where those students because of the
structure in which they sit in their
educational enclaves
cannot participate and when we plan for
and build an infrastructure to generate
economic development in a technopolis
knowing that we're planning for a future
without them
we have to be clear about what that
means and in the environment that we're
currently in which is why i began
this discussion that i did in the way
that i did because we're in a social
uprising here
we're contending with what it means to
be an american citizen
to be viable to have equal and human
rights to have your presence be
acknowledged
respected and cherished and if in the
specific specific lane of dealing with
technology we're planning for
futures without certain people it
conflates this other problem that we're
contending with
now so as we go forward our challenges
are clear these are things that
all of us are contending with and the
individual decisions that we're making
with our schools with our companies with
our non-profit organizations
etc but access resources
and philosophy access obviously is to
the kind of education that makes you
viable
the resources is the infrastructure that
makes those educational enclaves
uh palatable functional to make sure
that teachers are prepared
if you recall in the last two years
there were about 11 states where the
public school teachers across the
country were on strike
because of inadequate resources and what
does that all aggregate to
a philosophy what is our philosophy
about the utility
of education in the democratic republic
to make sure that
all of the students have the wherewithal
there are
all an integrated part of what a modern
technopolis
is so i would charge us charge myself
we're trying to consider what we do
and i think where we go from here
because the country is in such a flux
our bias is towards making a quick act
to try to bolster deficits that we can
easily see there aren't enough
uh devices there aren't enough students
in communities with broadband
connectivity
all of those things are important but my
argument
is in the consideration of race and
education
what we have to do here is we have to
contend with our philosophy
we're asking the educational the public
education
infrastructure in the united states
which i would argue
is one of the pillars of our democratic
republic
what is it that we are choosing to
invest in that
such that we don't a priori decide
that there are certain sets of students
who have essentially no
future irrespective of their own
abilities ambitions and capabilities
they don't have a future in this country
that we're trying to build
particularly one that is driven by a
technopolis
idea so those are the charges that i
think that we're up against
it's a moment for us all to consider the
very best of the original american
principles and a global sense of what it
means to be
human thank you much